attention listeners just a heads up that
this episode is especially visual
because the guys are taking us through
all of the best dance moments from 15
years of sunny so you might want to
consider becoming a creep just this once
and watch the podcast on youtube or
spotify to get the full picture
or don't do whatever the hell you want
i'm not your mom
now let's boogie ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the podcast we have a very
special podcast i'm excited about this
one i'm excited i'm very excited too meg
looks very excited over there
meg welcome back
thank you very much happy to be here no
you look different meg
yeah did you change your hair no you
were you changed your face you were gone
for an episode and it appears you
changed your face you changed your whole
persona i did
got a little curling iron got a hand
yeah that's good that's right well done
it looks great well meg has put together
uh
a fun little montage
apparently one little montage apparently
we've done uh quite a bit of dancing on
the show uh now i didn't think that we
had enough to put together a whole show
of dancing clips but apparently
uh we do i have not seen these clips
uh i've not seen this montage we're
gonna watch them for the first time
together in real time in real time baby
in real time however for the the creeps
who are uh listening or for the listener
of watching and for the listeners who
thought meg sounds different would you
like to introduce uh our meg replacement
yes
mauro could you introduce yourself to
america please and to the uk absolutely
america in the uk this is mara haran
reporting live from the sunny studios
the rcg happy to be here now mara's been
working on the podcast since day one
she's been behind the scenes and now
she's going to be out in front of camera
we're popping you in front today so here
we are we're going to watch uh
dancing there's a little bit there's
more dancing in the show than i think we
even realized i guess so and we're going
to kind of go through and we're going to
talk about these dancy moments and uh
we're going to have that'll be
interesting we're going to have a life
see i'm getting the sense that charlie
doesn't want to do this i know i do want
to do i just you know i like to i like
to be a little cervical yeah i do a
little while he likes to train this
isn't going to work otherwise we're just
like it's one of those shows where
everyone's just like agreeing and like
just like loving each other and like who
wants to listen to that yeah all right
listen
i'll i'll i'll fight with you guys about
something yeah yeah
well we'll find something we'll try
something to disagree about but how can
you have drama when you're dancing you
can't that's the answer
well that is i believe we've established
that as how people um of a modern era
navigate conflict through organized
choreographed dance
now i for one don't consider myself a
dancer i like to boogie at a wedding but
i don't i think you know that dancing is
a talent that some people really have
that i'm like yeah it's i don't have it
i mean
well it's one thing for professional
dancers to have it and that's always
impressive to see but it's it's always
equally um
mystifying when i see someone who's not
a professional dancer goes to say a
wedding and they can just dance yeah or
you go out into a nightclub which i used
to do back 20 years ago and you would
see just someone who you wouldn't assume
was a great dancer just be a great
dancer yeah are you just born you're
just born with rhythm or something
you know how to move your body well i'm
not one of those people was it
was it more of a thing where just like
everyone used to have to know how to
dance that you're like yeah
i think so i think i think i think more
people knew how to dance back in the day
because there was less to do
there was less to do
you wanted to find a mate you had to go
out there and prove your worth now
moving your body you just watch a show
about people who can dance come on do
you dance
yeah i danced for 25 years and we taught
for 15. yeah
it is perfect that you are subbing in
for this yeah there you go um i
jazzed ballet and hip-hop but then i
taught hip-hop for like 15 years holy
[ __ ] this is perfect all right this is
pretty amazing and you will be the dance
expert so i'll be judging no do we have
any video on that because i'd like to
see i'd like to see people
can we cut in some stuff okay
get some links because you could be
lying
yeah i could be lying it could be long
time i moved more to the choreography
side and like after because i just you
get old and but it's good that we'll
have an expert eye looking at this and
being able to talk about it so we need
to know who we're doing this against and
uh yeah yeah yeah so that's where the
conflict becomes yes yes we need some
okay so mara will maybe break some of it
down and we'll fight her okay great
great okay all right ready let's do this
oh i know it's yeah
oh well dancing well there's dancing
guys who's known for his dancing yeah
what is this
this is public access
now these were his moves yes he was not
received no director there's no
choreography no well there may have been
a choreography it was just only
happening in his head yeah yeah yeah yep
oh yep and now here's glenn oh this is
some this is some moves d-i-s-c-o
there's a guy
oh i love your show man so i'll say i'll
say as far as that goes that was a great
representation of
drug-fueled dancing yes club day thank
you yes
breathing really good like kind of like
deep breaths because the drug drugs were
pouring through your veins well you're
rolling this so i believe i was on
ecstasy right and i really like your
glow stick moves man those hand rolls
you know are they're tight they're quick
yeah it's interesting i i really am not
for the most part comfortable dancing in
front of people i don't like it
but maybe slightly more comfortable
doing it in character sure definitely
more comfortable knowing that the dance
is being fueled by a crazy drug right
that brings something to it gives me
something specific to do
and then the glow sticks having a prop
super helpful yeah because otherwise i'm
like i don't know what to do with my
[ __ ] hands like i'm all you know so
if you got the glow sticks and you make
it about that then then all of a sudden
you know because i've got decent rhythm
i just i just don't know what to do with
my body
and the good thing about the drugs is it
doesn't matter whether in real life
whether or not you're dancing well or
not that's right you're just having fun
yeah drugs will help you think you're
dancing really well sure yeah yeah yeah
sure yeah that's part of what they're
designed to do
[Music]
you know what we should do actually is
because charlie was dancing to a
different song
we should in the podcast
see what it would be like if you put
that queen's queen song back in just to
see how it is
like it's just the intro right so it's
just
yeah
i'd like to see that i'd like to see a
recut of that okay
[Music]
real tonight time charlie you look like
you've had some ballet training have you
in theater yes i studied ballet at the
um
london conservatory
for
uh no what makes you think that you see
arabesque and like your arm movements
like you just look like you i'm just
doing what i assume a dancer would do
very athletic got some technique i have
some athleticism but there's you know
the left leg that just doesn't i'm
spinning on the one leg that works yeah
yeah yeah
oh yeah here we go
i like that move what is that little
motorcycle that's pretty yeah not like
that though it's pretty good but you
gotta use a little bit more shoulder i
like the way he's doing it actually yeah
cause i'm i'm like i'm i'm bending the
bike but that's not really how you drive
a motorcycle yeah but you're not really
driving
okay
right okay so that's that's dancing at
each other
that's dancing versus each other
at some point we realized it was funny
to start a scene with a little bit of
inexplicable dancing well i don't that
wasn't i don't think any of that was
scripted i think that was something that
happened on the day like you just start
i don't remember why but you just
started doing that motorcycle dance that
was a move that was a that was yeah that
was a move in popular culture yeah
but then i think i call it i say i call
it by the name what did i say bending
the bike or doing something no he says
well he says i'm bet i was like he says
he's bending the bike and you don't like
that they're okay that's not really how
you drive a motorcycle
as if my character goes you wanted there
to be some veracity too country mac
drives a motorcycle sure you look up to
him yeah yeah no but i i think uh as i
recall none of this was in the script
and it just became like i think this was
a move
this was a move and saw in in popular
culture at the time it was from the
young jock video it's going down
you guys know that no but we'll put it
in the podcast
[Music]
[Applause]
danny doesn't know what we're doing so
he's like yeah what are they doing yeah
he's a little tuned in tokyo yeah he's
doing some tuna in tokyo yeah yeah
um okay
this is this is a classic absolutely
right this
is the kind of music now we hadn't
established that sweet dee was pregnant
but kaitlyn was very pregnant yes that's
true and she was very angry at the baby
at this point because she really she did
not think she did a very good job here
and she she wanted to nail it and she
wanted to fling her body around like
gummy bears she could have moved she
wanted to great got the moves does
anybody want any more catfish she does a
surprisingly good job of like following
along so you really yeah with the really
nailed that i'm also those things called
what are they called the inflatable
inflatables
man
yeah oh man i will say that that's
probably one of the most popular things
she gets on social media almost on a
daily basis
buy one of those things somewhere in the
in the world and they send that to her
yeah i'm really enjoying the uh the
musical the music as well so we're we're
we're being um
we're we're seeing the dancing and we're
also hearing some of the musical choices
this is a song that we that
this this
most people associate like i get so many
like you know whenever i post something
about like music that i'm listening to
people are always like what about higher
love what about some steve wynwood you
know people just
like steve winwood yeah joint 5678
but but
but
oh charlie no
wait where's this coming
so needy
you guys like it is it funny yeah sony
is so jealous
you're not having fun doing it so we're
not having fun watching it buddy
[Laughter]
sure that's coming in definitely
but but but
[Laughter]
oh he's having fun well so we're having
fun yeah i love me some sedace
and now we get into some real
choreography all right wait let's pause
real quick was this the first time we
had
a choreographer say okay here's the
dance here's the moves no
i don't wasn't the high school episode
before this
what season is this no it's the same
season it's the same season
but i think but i think we had done the
i think we had done
the choreography for the high school
episode
before before we shot the high school
one
the dance before we shot this yeah not
because obviously there's a lot of stuff
we shot in philly like in the parking
lot and stuff like that but i think all
the dance stuff i think that was the
first time it was the same choreographer
it was the same choreographer and either
way it was the first time whether it was
this episode of the other one was the
first time i've ever worked with a
choreographer ever
that was fascinating yeah and fun and
really fun but we just had didn't have
enough time well if we had more time all
the dances leading up to that are just
kind of us goofing around your body
however you're going to move it's going
to be funny and then this was like okay
it's a dance it has to look
specific
and that's a whole other animal when
someone's saying at this point in the
music your leg has to be here yeah and
then you gotta i'm just describing what
dances
what choreographed dancing but did you
so did you guys rehearse in a dance
studio or did they do it on set day of
no we rehearsed we were rehearsing but
we only had time if i think for both of
them we only had time for two rehearsals
we had more time we had more time for
the for the high school yes uh dance
this one came together very quickly and
we did not have a lot of time to
rehearse that i do remember that and did
they just like teach you a couple counts
of eight and then you repeated it or
they would teach you like a full minute
of all
i can't remember i just remember not
being able to question it
well i think we
we'll get to the part that i remember
specifically you know you not being i
just couldn't do it dude just couldn't i
couldn't count
now this is the greatest moment that's
the top top ten moments on the show
totally will you pause for a second no
this is pretty good
first of all that rob that that fat fat
mac uh wiggles very jolly very jealous
yeah very jealous
all of it it's just
that yeah let's say one more time
and also and we could also splice this
into the podcast this was based on
something that we had seen it was based
on a uh beauty pageant yeah yeah from
like the 80s or something or maybe the
90s where it was like it was miss
america or it was a big one miss usa and
this song was meant to emulate that
[Music]
and cormac wrote this one he wrote he
wrote all the music and letters to this
one uh no i think roselle
oh my god i think that rozelle and
martyr maybe i think they wrote the
lyrics both the words i think so
i don't even know what you're doing i
don't even know how you did i don't know
how you did that either but it's great
oh that's my favorites we nailed that
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
here she is frank's little beauties
[Music]
[Laughter]
glass and all that stuff these girls
will show you that they're good enough
they're good all right so put your hands
together and settle in because tonight
we're getting
[Music]
that rap i think he wrote the lyrics to
that rapture he might have written some
of it yeah yeah no i think he i do think
he wrote the lyrics to the rap yeah from
glass that seems like like all the like
uh uh magics in the air like okay silk
is everywhere i think that was marlon i
remember sabrina from wardrobe she she
came up to me and she was like um
you know i think we should get you a
larger shirt and i was saying i said why
and she said well because we can see
your gut like keeps sticking through and
i was i was like sabrina that's the
point like the whole point of the whole
season but she still kept like trying to
protect me throughout the whole season
god bless her you know i get that i get
that instinct i think you know i was
pulling it up so you can most actors
want to look as as good as they possibly
can so everything in her all of her
instincts are being fought yeah yeah
yeah but the cropped turtleneck makes it
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's the
whole thing that's awesome okay
such a good look did caitlyn take any
dance
i don't know
p.u
what are you gonna
just exactly what you're not supposed to
do with a kid is like keep secrets why
did the kid have the fake teeth
it's
to give her a perfect smile
oh that's right yeah yeah
[Music]
they're really getting those steps
yeah
it's the it's the um it's the growl she
puts into it though
vagina
oh my god
this is fantastic but that all that was
choreographed
and then this is just this kid
freewheeling right yeah oh no no the guy
helped there was choreography but i
think there was some improvisation and
and the three of us are basically like
we're doing basically a devo thing yeah
yeah we're kind of making ours up as we
go but
we're just doing like the robot and [ __ ]
back there right is that
[Music]
called chimes
i forgot we drew the abs on the kid
yeah yeah yeah
that's right
his dad
[Music]
what are you people doing to my son go
back to your scene all right who's in
charge here sir
i'll go back to yours
for a second i always love that like sir
go back to you like that the guy that
dad did a great job he's amazing
there's a sweetness to this because
we're letting the kid like be himself
yeah that's right
yeah just letting him dance you know
whatever i think this one
[ __ ] do it man that's right once the
expressing himself for once the you know
the other characters are big
[Applause]
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
drawn on abs yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
we've established those in the wrestling
episode yeah yeah the gang wrestles for
the troops the birds of war it's the
birds of war move yeah how we came up
with it that was last i don't remember
that was a last minute thing i think it
was a last-minute edition we were like
i think there was some discussion about
whether it would be funny to draw abs on
him or not
[Music]
i remember having a lot of fun with this
[Music]
oh
[Music]
yeah
your reaction to it how did you do that
oh
and this is the whole concept of it the
whole concept of plucking my eyes out
eating them them coming back up and
becoming your eyes becoming my eyes
i didn't tell you i was going to do that
right no no i i meant it was blowing
dennis is mine i know no i did not know
what you were doing
you reacted properly in real time yeah
yeah well
like if you've ever done like any kind
of like a drug like ecstasy or you know
molly or anything like that where
you know just everything's like
oh my god like i see the world a totally
different way now like
uh what are we sniffing here turpentine
yeah why are we still interpreting
oh we
we've given up on trying to be like our
best selves yeah
and we just want to get higher we're not
going worse yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
there's been a lot of negative energy
going on at the school okay so i want to
talk to you guys a little bit about
dancing
now back in the 50s and the 60s and 70s
people used to dance all the time that's
the way we solved our problems that's
how they solved their problems through
dance
then all of a sudden we stopped dancing
you know
grunge came in we dressed in in plaid
and oversized jeans then later on kids
wore trench coats and shot each other in
school and that's not cool but guess
what
guess what's going on in high school now
kids are dancing again organized
choreographed dance this was
very very choreographed and rehearsed
yes and of course us not being dancers
it took us forever we shot this whole
day which is
very unlikely like jill could learn this
choreography in 10 minutes
of course we established later that this
is all in our imaginations
yes that's right this is not what's
happening i also remember there being a
choreographer
a choreographer and
then he had a couple of other dancers
and they would show us the choreography
and we would do the choreography we
would do the moves exactly the way that
they're showing it to us but it looked
so different when they were doing it
because they knew how to dance stick
those lines man
like the line no matter how much we
practice over the course of two days and
then there's like an imbalance with us
where like someone hits it harder than
someone else and it does it all just
doesn't look
good but yeah that's okay i mean it
looks good enough
mm-hmm it looks pretty good yeah
[Applause]
showing up yeah everyone's loving it
and it took a while to cut this right to
be like oh what's the speed of the cuts
[Applause]
and then this is what's really happening
michael jackson homage
[Music]
oh glenn i like your moves
[Laughter]
so much energy you know what i mean yeah
i like the more erratic
breath
[Applause]
come on guys
yeah
yeah that's a good one
charlie fine love the dancing in this
oh yeah right of course
doing the doing the classic d of getting
too drunk when she likes a guy which we
established in season one
what the hell is she doing
she's gonna ruin this whole
getting the thing wrong yeah yeah
i love how free and uninhibited you are
[Laughter]
unchoreographed
yeah just a just a bad drunkest
backstroke
sloppy
lap dance well i got a question for you
guys so obviously she's she's very drunk
there do you guys feel like you dance
better when you're drunk or sober
drunk definitely what kind of dancing
just like well at an event
just like if you're at a wedding i would
have to be a little bit a little bit any
kind of like that but any kind of
choreographed stuff i'd have to be so
focused on dead
for sure fall down yeah i i don't mind
going to a wedding and just doing a
little bopping out there like that's
fine it's it's so much harder when it's
like no spin i'll get your leg here and
like yeah yeah yeah
my leg's like nah man no no man don't go
that high no don't do that i know what
you're telling me to do but i ain't
gonna do it i won't do it i won't do it
i refuse not for you not for anybody
yeah
all right
oh this is good oh yeah
[Music]
this has been something i've seen
daddy's moves better correct yeah
danny's got great little moves talking
about guys he's still got the movie i
mean playing online video games and
watching stupid reality shows that's not
real life it's keeping people from
experiencing real stuff
throwing some karate moves in there it's
real but it feels weird as [ __ ] there's
nobody else in the bar dancing what's up
frank motorcycle dance then others will
follow i'm stopping oh come on
let's go do some shots and that'll get
you guys fired up and we'll come back
out we'll do some more of this or
whatever you know you do the move and
come on come on come on
we're referencing every dance we've ever
done yeah elbow dance the
motorcycle that's characters forcing it
that's just that's just get like a man
trying to force a situation that's just
not not happening that's a good way to
just start a scene with three guys
dancing you don't know why they're
dancing
[Music]
we've returned with more products to
sell you
and this week the panhandling culprit is
mr glenn howerton
guilty his hair isn't growing back as
smoothly as he'd like so he needs a wig
in the meantime creeps and listeners
let's get the man some fake hair with
the help of our friends at helix sleep
you all know how much we love helix
mattresses they're top of the line
amazingly comfortable and as i like to
attest i've never slept better in my
life except under general stesia
general what
esthanesia got it but today we want to
focus on another aspect of their sweet
sweet package deal the fact that you get
to try them out for 100 nights
completely risk-free or days or days you
know shout out to our graveyard shifters
who hustle in the moonlight and sleep
throughout the day have you guys ever
slept through the day to quote tom hardy
i'm an actor of course i've slept
through the day yeah yeah i mean day or
night whenever you like to sleep doesn't
matter make sure it's on a helix
mattress okay take their two-minute
sleep quiz to determine the exact right
firmness fit for you and then enjoy the
best sleep of your life helix is
offering up to 200 off all mattresses
and two free pillows for our listeners
at helix sleep.com
sunny now again that's helixsleep.com
sunny
now
a word from our sponsor better help how
we care for our minds affects our entire
lives so it's critical to invest time
and energy into keeping them healthy one
of the best ways that we can do that is
through therapy like a better help
online therapy now in my experience
therapy
let me just see what my experience is
here really quick
therapy
is one of the most impactful ways to not
only check in with yourself
but to discover more beneficial thought
and communication practices to get you
through life yes and better help offers
video phone and even live chat therapy
sessions in case you don't want to see
anyone on camera but you still want to
give that brain a good old-fashioned
tune and
better help is also much more affordable
than in-person therapy did you do you
guys know that did you know that you can
be matched with a therapist in under
48 hours and best yet our listeners get
10 off their first month at
betterhelp.com sunny that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p-com sunny
go check it out
and live life
in the driver's seat he got it
he got it charlie got it i got it that's
prescriptive
[Music]
what's danny's reaction when you guys
tell him he's gonna do a dance scene
or dancing he's down he
you know
he's just got his funny little moves
that he does i mean
have you ever seen danny dance as danny
well when we did the whole choreograph
thing i don't remember danny's take on
it was he like
he just was down for whatever we're
doing right yeah he was definitely
struggling
uh
with the choreography
but i don't think it mattered that much
i don't know yeah he's always up for
learning yeah yeah yeah this is a good
one
[Music]
[Applause]
just enjoying the music
yeah yeah yeah yeah
why are we doing this
what are we doing is that what we do is
that what we say after that like why why
are we dancing i think so yeah yeah yeah
are we doing this yeah and then we find
out it's because a psychopath is in town
yeah yeah you guys know
i wasn't happy with that
institution yeah oh why would we dance
back yeah
all right this was all
[Music]
so here we're trying to like do a little
bit of the choreography like from the
weight loss yeah you know kind of yellow
brick road thing and then uh i remember
having a real hard time with this one oh
really there was like some movement
in it well it was it was because we were
trying to stay so in sync with each
other and so it was a lot of like oh
[ __ ] he's on his left foot we're
supposed to be on our right foot you
know like it was it was a lot of the
like just small details that we were
worried about because we wanted it to
look really and also in a in a real
performance in a movie or a stage
performance you would have weeks that's
right
and i think we probably went over it
twice especially with that especially
with actors who don't really yeah who
wouldn't even do this yeah
yeah also you guys in all of these like
the choreographed ones you have to keep
your formation you know so that's also
another thing you're trying to
remember the moves you're trying to like
sort of be aware of the spacing right
exactly it's a good location it's a nice
this is philly yeah yeah that's a nice
street
oh my god man i just had the weirdest
dream
the horrible beat boxing just makes it
all makes me very uncomfortable
so good
with the baseball cap yeah i we had a
thing there was something there was a
reason for it
i can't remember what it was either
finally a look on your face
find one
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
and you're watching me and so i come and
close the doors it's not meant for your
eyes just yet
not just yet
[Music]
okay
now this is carter this is carter yep
who also got bless his heart
knew nothing about dance i knew nothing
about dance
not a dance so this is so we were we
wanted this to feel like magic mike and
so we reached out to
alison falk who is the choreographer for
magic mike so she choreographed this and
i remember sitting in the um
back office and we were looking at the
monitors and i was talking to her and
she i was like i don't know how to dance
at all
but i would love to do something on the
show at some point where i just learned
how to dance just because to do
something different and she said oh just
call me i'll i'll teach you and so
that's what wound up happening i'm sure
we'll get to that that that that's
that's she choreographed the yeah the
dance that you did yes the next season
was the fourth i know it was either next
season or season after that
it was 13 yeah
what season is this uh this might be 12
12.
yeah so i just kept her contact and then
the following year
i asked her how long would it take me to
learn how to do something more
substantial and she said months months
yeah a long time because you've got to
start from scratch that's right well
yeah that's right and it did and it was
months months months we'll talk about
that
god bless him
god bless him for doing this
[Music]
yes this is amazing
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah very very upsetting
god bless carter for being so game to uh
because i could tell you know he was he
was like
he was he knew it was funny he knew it
was worth it yeah but it was not
something that he you know
yeah no one wants nobody wants to work
he wants to do that who doesn't well no
but do it for a living you look good
yeah
yeah
guys we're gonna bring it down for a
minute here yeah i'm gonna bring it down
for four and a half minutes
[Music]
it's long todd biermann directed this
correct yeah
yeah so so alison um
falcon leo moctezuma are the uh
choreographers
dancer is uh a woman named kylie shaik
so she's a legit ballerina yeah yeah
she's yeah and she would pick it up so
fast and i would just she would come in
for an hour and then i would and then
she would leave and i would work with
allison
and leo for
for hours
but again it was just like like if i
didn't know you and i didn't know i'd be
like oh it's just two professional
dancers out there dancing you know like
you really i mean you can see it man you
can see
where
you don't have the
sort of like the foundation of the form
however
for a non-dancer
who's never really danced
you know you get you've got some pretty
good lines i mean you you know
thank you yeah i mean it was it was
truly months like right there that
always bugged me
and bugged you because you felt like you
could get right like i couldn't quite
get the spin right yeah the a lot of the
stuff like where i throw her around
that's
that was easy because that's just you'd
been i was in good shape and then again
just practice but then we didn't add the
water until so we i kind of got it down
in in a stance studio
like for but that movie i mean you
nailed that yeah
well once we added the water it became
infinitely more dangerous
right
just became we also shot this on
different cameras than we shoot our show
on yeah actual nice cameras that look
good much more stylized
much more better much more much more
better yeah but like you see how it's
soft focus yeah they're like our cameras
are always one continuous photo so we
were using our cameras though on the
audience no no oh no both both sides
yeah otherwise you want to have the
whole
house
what's great with working the reason by
the way for the audience is that i'm
asking all these questions i had nothing
to do with this episode i'd stepped away
from the writers room so i i don't know
that much about it oh yeah that's right
yeah and we would um we would be in the
writers room i think i would go
over to allison's studio twice a week or
sometimes three times a week for
like three months i remember you were
working on it a lot yeah a lot
that's a good shot that todd did that's
like crashing in on you guys yeah yeah
would he have a dolly down for that how
many times did you i don't remember how
many times did you do the dance a lot
wow
we did it all day it was like a full day
of shooting the dance yeah right but
again i was in good shape and i had been
practicing
for a long time so i had the energy
but but i was
that was [ __ ] awesome that's cool
that's great [ __ ] amazing yeah that's
amazing and she did that
you know like the first day that's good
for him rob oh this moment's
[Music]
it amazing danny nailed it um he's just
you know he has these danny has these
moments on it where you're like
yeah there's a reason why you're a giant
movie star because you're a [ __ ]
great actor they're a phenomenal actor
phenomenal yeah well i trained for four
months
to get that right and right together
right he just stepped right in it yeah
but that's what that's what the scene is
about and should be about that's what
the whole episode's about that's right
it's his catharsis
that's exactly right
oh it's both it's both it was an
incredible experience that the the
i think the
the best part was how patient they were
like
allison
and leo and kylie were so patient
because they knew i was a non-dancer so
probably if they would get frustrated if
it was another dancer but they would
just like keep showing me running it
running it running and running it do you
feel like you
that this was a transformative
experience for you in your life doing
this dance
getting in this shape for this season
like i feel like you have continued to
be obviously you're bigger in this
episode like bigger muscles but you've
maintained
the same sort of level of fitness of the
guy who could do this
since this moment you know
i i just had so much fun and there was
something about the discipline of having
to
go through not only learning something
completely new but then the fitness it
would take to keep doing it and i felt
good i felt so good yeah so i don't feel
as good as i did then but i wasn't
drinking really i wasn't i was just
working out constantly and then also
just the endorphins that get released of
learning something
new and exercising that much so i try to
keep up with some of that
but
and dance works out every part of your
body like you start to feel you're like
what every part of your arm but you did
such a beautiful job rob you should be
really proud thank you and the patience
i think is the hardest is like having
patience for yourself learning it and
not being like [ __ ] you know because
it's hard but also realize how much is
this mental like how much you don't i
don't realize how much of dance is
mental is like putting the and having
the allowing for the neurons to make
connections and as you're using a
handout yeah in some ways like if you're
if you really are thinking about the
choreography it's actually harder for
you to get it you know what i mean you
kind of have to like
feel it a little bit you know what i
mean it's like it's almost like trying
to memorize your lines and forgetting
the intention behind the line
sometimes like if you get if the
choreography really flows nicely and you
understand the intention behind it and
you just feel it
it's there for you when you need it you
know in the same way that like
now i know i'm sure you guys are the
same way you get to the point where you
get so used to memorizing lines like if
you understand the thought you
understand the intention
you just trust that the line will come
to you when it's time
um you know and i think it's probably
the same way with dance i would say
right i mean you can't because
because you can see his the emotion on
your face so like the moves were a part
of you you weren't like five six seven
yeah yeah yeah
like concentrating on that but once yeah
once you get the choreography inside it
just becomes part and you just it's that
feeling and you trust yourself you trust
yourself but only for knowing that you
knowing that you couldn't just because i
mean
knowing that you couldn't it would be
very tempting because you know we're all
very busy and you're very busy and you
know to just be like i'm sure i can
learn this in three weeks
you know what i mean but you knew you
were like this has to be
like way beyond anything that we've ever
done choreographed and
well also with the tones of what the
episode was saying we knew it couldn't
be a joke like a typical sunny episode
right there's plenty of jokes leading up
to it but like once you got to this it
couldn't be
one of our like oh it's kind of funny
because he's doing it half bad like it's
all or nothing right you're either going
to nail that or you can't do you can't
have that be the end of the episode yeah
um
because the funny version of that just
wouldn't work it would be it'd be a
different thing you know
yeah well tr tr i hear i heard mauro
mention this a couple times and you
brought up glenn that trust is a huge
part of it like you have to you have to
trust that you're going to pull it off
you have to trust that people aren't
going to laugh at you
you have to trust your partner because
you're you're putting them you're i was
putting her and the choreographer um was
putting her into potentially dangerous
situations and and vice versa where
she's got to make sure that i'm not
going to drop her or i'm not so all
through the whole process you're
trusting that you can do it and you're
trusting your partners to be there for
you you're trusting that the
choreographer
understands your limitations but also
what you're capable of and it just feels
like a lot of any of the artistic
you know expression that we do in acting
or any kind of performative art you're
trusting the other people in the room
and and you're trusting the audience
that they're going to go along with it
as well can i ask you a question about
like so as you were learning obviously
you had to learn the choreography but
i'm sure they had to teach you
like form right and and what and like
lines and like you know like what your
hand is supposed to be doing because i
mean you have to you know it's not just
what your arm is doing it's all the way
down to your fingertips like were you
having to learn yeah all that about like
pointing your feet when it's time to
point your feet and
stuff like that yeah and and then
visualizing what what could she would
say things like about your fingertips
like taking it all the way out to your
fingertips and i'm like what does that
mean i don't even know what that means
not about how you point them but how you
what you're supposed to feel in them and
it's just more about visualizing what
that is and then also
retraining my brain to think well in my
mind that doesn't look right and then
she would take a photo of it and i would
look at it and i would say oh that that
does look right or something that looks
cool
it's just like choreography uh like
choreographing a fight you know you hear
a lot of you hear a lot of um fight
choreographers talk about professional
fighters and how they're the worst
they're the heart it's the hardest
people to train to do a movie fight
really because sometimes if something
looks like is
technically right right it doesn't look
good on screen oh yes that's right so
it's a totally different skill it's a
totally different elbow like way higher
than you ever would for a punch so that
like crosses yeah so that you're seeing
the arm otherwise it happens too fast
yeah or it's too low and the camera
misses it yeah so so something similar
here where they would
pitch something and it wouldn't feel
right and then they would record it and
it just looked right yeah
and so you just have to trust them and
then i don't know it's also an amazing
community of people um the dance
community and that was the first time
i'd ever been introduced really to
to to so many people in it but
you know there's not a ton of money in
dance like maybe the top five percent of
people make a really great living
everybody else is doing it because they
love it because it's it's an artistic
expression that it just speaks to them
and always has so jill and i both love
so you think you can dance we watch
i haven't seen every season but i've
seen a lot um
and that's always been one of the things
i was always like why do i like this so
much well obviously it's amazing because
the dancers are like
beyond incredible on that show
um so the actual performances are just
stunning to watch but i think the thing
that i've always
really liked about it is
i've always been skeptical of
competition shows because
if i get a whiff that someone is doing
something
and their goal is to become famous
i don't then all of a sudden like i'm
like i don't trust the art i don't trust
the thing because it's like
you know sometimes with like american
idol and those like those kind of
competitions you just you're like
i don't know that you really care that
much about singing but you like the idea
of being a pop star and that just kind
of taints it for me
and as a dancer like because
there's so few people who actually could
ever become rich off of it or you know
or even famous for being a dancer
and the level of dedication and
difficulty that to become a dancer at
that level uh it's just like
and to do it knowing that you know at
best you'll be able to you'll work and
you'll make money and but you're never
going to be you know so it's like it
doesn't it's not tainted for me i think
that's what i like about well siddiqua
says it in the com the comedy version of
it is when sadakis says and it's totally
true uh well you're not having fun so
i'm not having fun watching it and
that's exactly right like if that's goes
for any discipline where if it and i
think maybe that's part of the charm of
the show is that it it's clear that
we're having fun making it and i think
people are on board with that yeah and
so i think it's the same thing here
where i i i think it's clear that the
people who are involved in this entire
process loved what they were doing
and
i think it comes through
i'm curious about the fan feedback from
this like what was some of that like
what have you heard from
fans about the performance it was
overwhelmingly positive yeah i think
it's just because of the tone of the
entire episode and where the character's
arc was going which is very un
sunny right um but again i think that's
why people enjoy sunny too is that we
are um
not giving them the same episode over
and over and over i mean i feel like
with their work criticisms it was just
that we sort of betrayed the existing
tone of the show by doing something that
was deadly serious and i think this was
the first time
in one of the few times ever that we've
done that where she was like
to this degree to this degree to this
length which is not just like a moment
but an
entire four or five minutes of not sorry
no jokes and ending the episode like
sorry nothing yeah which is fair which
is fair i get it surely but yeah but i
think we reserve the right at this point
um especially when we're trying to do
something com effort as long as we've
been doing it to mix it up and try those
same people would be complaining about
being bored that we keep doing the same
things over and over again if if we did
if we don't
get everybody happy
hey guys today we are supported by huel
a nutritionally balanced plant-based
meal made in less than a minute okay so
if you're looking for a product that
will simplify your routine and it's also
nutrient-dense yeah well that's just it
right i mean i i eat only for function
you know for sustenance i've long said
if i could ingest a nourishment paste
and get all my daily nutrition i would
do that now all you do is add two scoops
of fuel to water shake and boom you've
got your nutrition solution of the
future ready to go unfortunately for you
it's much better than a paste yeah now i
know i love the huel black edition
because it's super high in protein it
comes in eight flavors that taste great
including cookies and cream chocolate
vanilla and salted caramel each portion
of huel starts at just two dollars and
50 cents a meal think of the time and
money that you're going to save on food
you don't want to spend it on in the
first place yeah and then think about
all the other things you could spend it
on to bring yourself actual profound joy
name anything clothes well buddy you are
in luck because the stars keep aligning
for you today okay cause you go to
huell.com sunny you're gonna get a free
t-shirt that's right and
a free shaker with your first order
that's yule h-u-e-l-dot-com
sunny to get a free t-shirt and a free
shaker with your first order go do it do
it now go
fellas when you're getting hot and heavy
nothing is a bigger boner kill than
bone or kill fortunately that's where
blue chew comes in to help you know
they're a unique online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
viagra or cialis but in a chewable form
and at a fraction of the cost bluetooth
tablets help men combat all forms of ed
and provides harder longer lasting
erections yeah bluetooth is an online
prescription service there are no
doctor's visits you don't have to
describe why you're coming in over the
phone or not coming at all you don't
have to repeat it to the nurse and then
repeat it again to the doctor you don't
have to deal with any of the awkwardness
at the pharmacy blue chews licensed
medical providers work with you to find
the right ingredient in strength for
your prescription and did we mention
that that it's all done online online
this is the future friends future is
online i don't know if you know this the
click of a button and then boom
boner tablets right to your door work
smarter and harder
and here's a special deal for our
listeners try bluetooth free when you
use our promo code sunny at checkout
just pay five dollar shipping go to
bluetooth.com promo code sunny to
receive your first month free
would any of you guys do dancing with
the stars
hell no no no okay i didn't think so
all right not because of the dancing
though
because of the stars
yeah yeah more because it would feel
like a
has been yeah yeah
it feels like to me and yeah yeah i'm
sorry also i just don't have injured
like it just doesn't interest me you can
finally like sign up for dancing with
the stars only to find out that uh
you're not the star you're dancing with
somebody who's a bigger star
i thought i was the [ __ ] so you're the
dancer oh you're on the dance floor
there's been a mistake there's been a
mistake yeah
all right
is that the last no
two more oh great more
[Applause]
this scene was really hard to cut
together remember charlie yeah we spent
a lot of [ __ ] time on this i don't
know why that's a lot why are we doing
it
roller skating was trickier than i
thought it was going to be well now you
grew up you grew up playing hockey you
grew up on ice skates i i knew it was
just i escaped
it's been a while since i've been on
either but
we should have put you on blades but
that just doesn't have the same right
look that doesn't have the right look to
it you know they've got to be on four
wheels blade ring
yeah this is not the right thing it's
not the right thing you know
um
you pulled it off you pulled it off it's
a little scary moved around yeah yeah
it's okay
it's okay
oh here we go okay here we go yeah
so these girls are all yes like
skaters and caitlyn
[Music]
[Music]
she was having a hard time just standing
still
and we want to give away which parts are
i think it's pretty obvious right which
parts are her which parts are
stunt double
caitlyn with the stunts yeah boy
she could practically be a stunt man at
this point it's not a person
it's not person
well that was the stunned person in that
right yeah we are
that was the the running into the wall
actually hitting the wall yes that was
the stunt performer yes i see the magic
of hollywood you didn't even know didn't
it even
well i look forward to years of dancing
with you with you all because that's the
other thing there's a time stamp on a
dancer like at 25 right you're old
so it's a lot different than like an
aging comedian tough on the body yeah
the aging community an aging comedian at
45.
aging clowns
have
middle-aged dancing clowns have a
tougher time seriously
young jock it's going down
and that's where you go that's where you
do that
yeah you gotta
i mean if you do if you're doing your
bike right
they're all the way up here yeah they're
serious yeah you're riding like this you
got the airplanes
nice
organized choreographed dance
you